ladies and gentlemen please welcome your
host your far Abdul Kareem welcome to
every one of you Alan Ross Alan hats
leash will comment on bienvenidos it's
an amazing view to look here into the
room and see different people from
different cultures and to feel the
energy that is here in the room you have
people from different cultures different
backgrounds different political point of
view might agree disagree but we all
share the same values freedom of
expression freedom of speech the open
exchange of ideas and these are the
values of Deutsche Welle global media
forum it's about coming together and
discuss that's why ladies and gentlemen
welcome to 11th edition of the Bob's
2015
we all are gathered here to honor brave
creative bloggers Internet activists and
journalists who don't only believe in
these values by they risk their daily
lives in order to give others a voice to
express themselves welcome and this year
we got more than 4,800 candidates who
competed in 14 different languages and I
think it's time to look behind the
scenes and knowing how hard was the
decision of the juries and I can tell
you it wasn't easy but at the end they
decided and it's also important to know
their importance of their work of the
online activists and that's why let's
watch this movie now together
freedom of speech in a world full of
conflict getting information often means
being at the center of the struggle it's
online activists bloggers and
journalists all around the globe who
fight for it every day there on the
scene in locations often shaken by war
censorship and despotism the people who
push the button and frame the moment the
online communities that try to change
the offline world doncha Bella has been
honoring their commitment for 11 years
the bobs recognizes the best blogs and
online activists this award has its own
way to bringing the local initiatives
done all over the world to the public
eyes of the world is a way to show them
that they can make the difference they
can change the world for the better any
online activism is really have direct
effects on offline evert there were more
than 4,800 candidates this year and they
competed in three categories social
change arts and media and privacy and
security the project showed the variety
present in the world wide web from
Facebook pages to podcasts from video
games to apps
the winners had to convince an
international jury of 14 internet
experts not take place
it's gonna find the support of many
people from very different cultural
contexts and I think that's the main
issue was so hard to build the Bob's it
was just impossible to choose and I
might have gained a couple of grey hairs
today evening to get the choice it's
very difficult problem but I make the
choice with their decision the jury
hopes to once again empower outstanding
online activists to continue to make a
change as you can see some God gray
hairs other were saying oh it's a really
hard decision but at the end they had to
choose and they actually did I'm going
to introduce you the first category
which is social change and the winner in
social change is muck to Munna muck to
Munna is the biggest platform for
freethinkers and atheists in Bengali
language but this year one of the one of
the founders at the founders of MOOC to
Munna was silenced average it Roy one of
the most powerful powerful voices of
this platform he was on a list among 80
around 80 activists who were on the list
that was published by religious
extremists and since 2013 nine of them
were murdered but there's with hundreds
of bloggers and especially his widow
continued this work because they want to
keep his spirit and his message alive
in a country with a secular Constitution
but shaped by his mom a country where
atheist is a swear word lvg dry died for
his beliefs he believed in freedom of
speech and that's what he fought for and
he was not only an atheist or just the
writer or a blogger he was a secular
humanist who dealt with the bigger
questions of life after he was murdered
in February alva G dries widow has been
continuing his work
mactan Mona is the world's largest
online community in Bengali for
freethinkers with contributions from
inside and outside Bangladesh in a
country where there is so much
repression in a country where operating
as an activist is so fraught with danger
the fact that these young bloggers have
taken that position and insisted upon
their message message is being heard and
i think is very powerful with the
support of hundreds of others rafita
ahmed is keeping mactan mona going
[ __ ] dries ideas live on I know that we
will not be silenced there can be a
world without religious superstitions or
you know bindings based on science and
reason and where you speak out against
all oppression
I'm joined now by Shahid Alon what I
told you you're one of the Godfather the
Bob's have been there like five more
five years right yeah I get rid of it no
no no we want you here it's important to
be with us and my question is today how
important are the Bob's the word of
online activism well mainstream media of
course is incredibly important but it
does have the problem of having very
powerful entities establishment
political forces corporate agencies but
controlling and one of the things that's
happening is the online community is
taking it on board to express things
that mainstream media sometimes will not
talk about but there is the reverse of
this because the online media now has to
establish its credibility has to be
accepted and I think something like the
Bob's does precisely that by this very
important award I think it establishes
the credibility of the bloggers it gives
in space yeah and I take a degree of
protection and and the category social
change their winner is mook tome una y
[ __ ] tamuna I think you did mention that
there was tough contest but this was one
of the areas where the judge judges were
largely united was clearly ahead of the
rest in terms of the risk it took in
terms of what it was trying to do in
terms of the clarity of its vision and
you just look at that woman that it's
incredible that she and her fellow
bloggers have continued to do the
marvelous work they do and my hats off
to them yes and that's I think it's time
to work on the feeder I might please
join us
it's Europe out
hmm
la vida you have you have suffered a
tragic loss your husband average average
at Troy was murdered while you were
walking with him in the streets of tak
of the capital of bangladesh your you
your own have also 7th knife steps and
and now nevertheless you continued the
work what makes you keep on going I
think it is the mock timona community
who gives us the courage the the passion
to continue the passion I was in ICU in
Bangladesh in America for a few weeks
actually and there were a group stronger
bigger old faces new faces came in they
they got together they actually took
MOOC timona ahead we had technical
problems was getting hacked it we had
other issues but they came forward and
moved it forward and and you personally
what's what's making you looking forward
what were you getting your strength I
mean it's from this Community actually
that you know if they didn't stop there
are hundreds of people who are actually
sending me messages supporting me I and
the support they have shown in
Bangladesh after Bridget's dead the
statements came out the way they got
United you know it was amazing it was
very encouraging to see a lot of us here
don't know a vicious Roy in person what
do you think what would he say today
getting this prize oh I actually he
started multa Mona before I met him I I
met him through a mocha Mona a year
after he started it trust me a lot of
our communications we're about muko Mona
like he was so passionate even when it
was a small yahoo group you know he
started from that moved it big made it
out of website then a blog then he
created a world of activism surrounding
by it
um like his books all the books he wrote
or anybody else from oh come on the road
timonium was the center of it it was
like a child to him so he would be very
happy and we are really happy that
you're joining us here today I just have
one question is how you're doing today
where are you living and and I mean what
you're doing in the daily life are you
being threatened what support you need I
am Here I am I guess I am okay
physically recovering still going
through treatments especially my head
injuries they're gonna take a while but
i am not so worried about myself at this
point i don't know what worse can happen
I guess I can die but then I'm gone but
but I am worried about the bloggers you
know they have killed another to
bloggers after of idiots death like an
uncle was very close to us he was a
great warrior forum of Dimona as well
and now all these bloggers in Bangladesh
are getting threats death threats and
it's almost like they're haunting them
yes so they are in trouble right now and
we hear from the box we want to send a
signal to this butter let's do these
bloggers and to you and that's why
you're the winner in the social change
over please Shah
thank you so much pick up last mr. Ravi
that much
and now we had to the next category
which is arts and media the winner in
this category is they tune the little
refugee different activists from all
over the world have one thing in common
and it is that they are refugees so they
ask themselves what can we do what
should we do to let our voice be heard
and make more awareness concerning the
refugees and that's why the online video
game they tuned the little refugee was
born the initiator and the creator of
this online game is Mohammed tired we're
going to know more about his story and
when you look at his story it's a lot
part of the video game
he was a Palestinian refugee in Syria
now he's a Syrian refugee in Europe in
exile he's found a creative way of
telling his story I have really loved
angers me because because likes in
supposed to this situation and feeling
like what the whole world ignorance like
you feel you can explore inside if you
like you want to tell something that the
what don't want to listen the story
begins here yarmouk is serious biggest
Palestinian refugee camp it's been under
siege since the war broke out Mohammed
developed a video game based on his
experiences at the camp the player
becomes a refugee himself it is actually
very beautifully designed it is very
powerful it is special that it is a
project that it is a video game and at
the same time is an archive of Syria
Palestine history and the history of
refugees in the region
oppression made Bahamut flee from Syria
and made him a refugee once again now in
Madrid like I'm living in two places at
the same time emotionally I'm I'm Thiago
can physically I'm not here we're always
connected
I'm now joined by Lyle and sweaty one of
the jury member nice having you here
with us hi yeah nice nice having you
here Lila please could you tell us why
did you choose the project site owner so
it's a very outstanding project and we
think is very timely in this in this
moment so first there's the issue of
refugees as a whole and they're a
pressing issue and there should be a
share that responsibility international
yet they're quite neglected but there
are not only passive victims they only
they also have a voice that we should
listen to and it is expressed in first
person through projects like that that's
on the word on one hand on the other
hand it's also the issue of Syria and
Palestine because this is a tune is a
refugee in Syria first from Palestine
then his camp got bombed by the Assad
regime so he had to flee also Syria and
now he's a refugee somewhere else oh the
the you know amount of isolation that
these people are going through and also
it's a it's actually trying to invoke
the spirit of the beginning of the
uprisings when there was a shared goal
of justice and dignity which is actually
something that unites the Syrian and
Palestinian struggle in a context of
increasing fragmentation thank you for
the explanation and now I think it's
time to welcome the winner in arts and
media mohammed sahib
no you say
hamid noise and welcome to have you here
with us i'm gonna switch to arabic
because hamid could express himself more
and understand me Hamid oh well I wants
to our lien skazala why do you cover
yourself covering my face because many
activists in Syria all over the world
have been threatened some of them have
been killed so this is a way to protect
our collective attention I have been
with you since the past two days on I
just noticed that there is a command
anger inside of you so how do you how do
you express that I'm angry because the
whole world and international community
ignores us we suffer from a lot of
problems and nobody takes care of us so
that's quite normal to be angry so I
think that I'm expressing something to
like them more than a person order in
the movie you said that you have a voice
but nobody listens to you you'd be what
in front of their dozens of cultures
identities and they have millions of
people watching you over deutsche
village so you can express yourself so
i'd like to say thank you very much for
you all it's an honor for me to be here
it's time today to cancel nationalities
citizenship passwords religious and to
be just humans just humans
shukran lilac thank you very much he is
former English with it so much lighter
and now we will be heading to the next
category which is privacy and security
and the winner and this category is
Rancho electronical group of online
activists came together and said it's
enough everything is being done with our
data but no we don't want to accept it
what they are doing is to make a lot of
awareness concerning data security and
data protection but what makes a branch
electronical so special is did they only
do it online they actually leave the
virtual life and they go to the offline
life and help people by doing events and
supporting them
the people of Rancho electronico are
fighting for change for more data
security and less surveillance but
they're fighting forward in a country
that's struggling with corruption and
crime it's so not formally poder it's a
way of reacting to all the things that
are going on in Mexico from here we're
organizing the resistance through the
internet looky organizada there's the
last raid days the hackerspace Rancho
electronico is a cooperative trying to
serve safe and protect privacy but in
Mexico these topics seem trivial to many
people
nevertheless the Rancho is spreading its
knowledge to try to make a change
sending bullet I'm not there empowering
young people to take control of their
digital tools to retain digital autonomy
the impact they will have is that people
we digitally empower the lon cho
electrónico wants more freedom in real
life and online no sorry not only in
Mexico the world needs more places like
this one
well it seems that they are also having
fun by what my first question to you do
you think branch electronic reflect the
spirit of the young people in Mexico are
there different I think they were quite
unique actually and they are exceptional
and we need more exceptional people like
them because we often forget that in the
digital age encryption anonymity and
privacy in general are essential tools
to exercise not only our right of
freedom of expression but other rights
like their right to organize ourselves
peaceful assembly and so many other
rights and there's exactly working on
that yeah what's the message that the
jury of the Box wanted to say and give
when did you choose Rancho electronica
they are they have a unique link with
the global but they are acting locally
so it will be as we are seen here with
with many people supporting bloggers in
prison Ethiopia China Iran and so on
they do the same with Western dissidents
event you know they are the other places
at the offices of a branch electronico
you can find posters in support of
Edward Snowden of chelsea manning of
jeremy hammond barrett Brown and all
these people who are using technology to
exercise the right to freedom of
expression access to information and so
on from there so is a connection they
are acting locally and they are teaching
and educating the community look locally
but they are also linked to this global
movement for freedom of speech thank you
for let us know and now it's time to
welcome the room at the winner Omar
valenza please join us
you're going to give it to him
yep just short I thought you would work
but it's okay nice having you here with
us I'm gonna speak I keep in english
because i only know in Spanish guitar I
think it's not enough to do the
interview now ok so I'm going to talk in
English and you can go in as in Spanish
and the first question is like what's
the biggest challenge you're having a
near daily life like let us know about
your daily life doing this place cookies
but I think first to be alive in the
country which is then oppressing us we
have 46 when I'm day dress will have 43
different people who have this
disappeared in chanapa 43 students who
disappeared and we have all in all
24,000 people who have disappeared and
also journalists and also people from
the United States have disappeared in
Oaxaca and this is our challenge
actually and with it well and after that
I think that all the other things is
getting organized in this on that note
we are using also the tools or for
example decoding tools in order to also
make sure that we are sure that we have
high security level here and how is the
resonance from the young people
especially is if you see it's difficult
because my desk reporter Sione's we have
different corporations copiado ah miss
el internet que vamos internets we are
also building the internet it's not the
internet of the company's stuff from
Facebook Google or Microsoft but it's
gooey resonance iya do not turn off a
higher version than see ya but we have
de cuentas locust on the ends what we
are doing is that we are trying to
getting organized we know that we are
only a few but we
of a big hard and I think this is what
is important for the ranch electronic
copy and we have also other shares which
projects which way I can share with her
for example aveda and let me love songs
and Sam so this is no these are the
hearts which we want to reach one friend
in estes island and um okay celos que
que tamos yo Gotti's we want to reach
the hearts maybe of the people who are
here in this room
and one thing I try to write to you in
facebook I couldn't write to you what's
up no what's up how do you communicate
cuz three in the mistress well we are
building our own tools nah so soon Libra
is a movement it's not a technics
consumer but it's a political movement
and it's it concerns everybody here
because we do not know when things will
change and you call it for example
freedom of expression but for me doesn't
really exist because you can't guarantee
life and therefore this is not any
freedom and what do we have to do we
have to make a reflection we have to
discuss how we are using the tools which
we are getting birthday now so
benefiting from this and they are
benefiting from our information from our
benim privacy thank you so much and yeah
so today it's the 11th edition but we
also have it from here today it's the
first time there's a special award this
year for people who stand for the brave
and fearless commitment to human rights
for freedom of expression today we have
a special award and it is their freedom
of speech a word and it goes to the
imprisoned relief battery right if
Beddoe is a Saudi Arabian blogger who
was jailed three years ago and he's
being there till for 10 years in prison
and 1,000 lashes and you know why it's
just because he created the website free
Saudi liveris
his fate has shocked the world his crime
expressing his opinions his sentence 10
years in jail and 1,000 lashes la lana
digital wattpad and a buscarlo mcteer
Lana the demonstrations have really been
a support for anything me and given us
strength Althea Tina oh I have the
feeling that the whole world is behind
us and i asked the world to continue
supporting us until rife is free Elena
hyah a la maravilla told her yet oh
sorry Arabia's Supreme Court has just
upheld the barbaric verdict only a royal
pardon could end the torture a crowd
watched his first fifty lashes he still
has another 950 to go well I animals on
me acaba health wise he's not doing well
he has problems with his blood pressure
and psychologically he's also not doing
well oh well done enough cipa Bannister
brave battle Ruiz wife and South has
been fighting relentlessly for the last
three years to get her husband out of
prison together with the couple's three
children she now lives in Canada
the tunnel is your eyes wickham I hope
that riot can once again be with us with
his family hey that's all I hope for
please welcome with me the keynote
speaker for the freedom of speech a word
editor-in-chief of sight online mr.
johann wagner the stage is yours so
ladies and gentlemen it may be that the
freedom of speech aboard for right but
I've is the most important price ever
given out by the Bob's certainly this
award ceremony is among the most bitter
rifa Tommy cannot be with us today for
the last three years he has been locked
away in a Saudi Arabian prison convicted
of having founded an internet firm that
violates Islamic values and propagates
liberal thought as part of the verdict
only recently upheld he is also
subjected to torture he is to receive
1,000 lashes if he doesn't die first
even today right Bobby and his family
subordinate their own personal happiness
so as to continue taking advantage of
the self-evident right of free speech
but right but avi is not just an
advocate for free speech he's also a
champion of secularism and the
separation of church and state and
despite knowing full well that his views
clashed with the Saudi mainstream he
shared them openly until he was
forbidden from working as a journalist
yet even then he continued to write in
the internet in 2008 he founded the
website free Saudi liberals as we're
before hoping to create a platform for
others to speak freely as well that
saying here he was arrested and
interrogated for the first time on
suspicion of apostasy of turning his
back on Islam crime punishable by death
he was released but a few months later
the state banned him from leaving the
country and froze his accounts rife
adavi kept writing but after his wife
received threats over the phone he asked
her to go into exile with the children
if you will allow me brief aside the
city of Quebec
on to the family asylum and recently
offered it to right but are we as well
in public Canada can be proud of itself
I wish that all European countries where
the right to asylum is currently a
subject of intense debate would compete
with Canada to make such offers of
asylum rather than competing among
themselves for the privilege of
exporting arms to our allies Saudi
Arabia
and by the way i also wish germany would
stop acting as a stooge for questionable
governments by arresting journalists on
their behalf as it recently did in the
case of our respected colleague ahmed
mansour who thankfully has been released
rice Barack continued writing and still
writes today from prison he dictated to
his wife the forward to his book of
selected blog entries a volume that was
recently published in Germany and will
soon be published in the u.s. two or
three times per week is allowed to call
his wife that means that right but are
we will hear about this price he will
come to know how inspiring he is for us
and how deeply we are moved by his fate
but as important as our support is for
him right but obvious just as important
for us for one reifer da we has opened
our eyes seldom has Saudi Arabia's pizza
frania been so obvious as it was on the
ninth of January when rife badami
received the first 50 lashes for the
propagation of liberal thought on the
internet two days before his lashing
Islamist terrorists had murdered several
journalists from Charlie Hebdo because
of their propagation of liberal
caricatures two days after his lashing
members of the Saudi government
participated in a demonstration on the
streets of Paris a demonstration in
support of the freedom of speech rarely
has Saudi Arabia schizophrenia been sold
visible right where r is important to us
because he has opened our eyes but he's
also important to us as an example to
aspire to I'm not jolly and I'm not
right but are we either indeed it would
be presumptuous to make such a claim
with each and every one of his blog
entries rife madhavi risk more than most
Western journalist journalists risk
during the course of their entire Korean
yet i would like to seek to hold up the
courage shown by rife but are we as an
example i may aspire to I very much hope
that many journalists and activists try
to live up to his example and do not
cease dedicating themselves to defending
the right of free speech right but avi
has a great deal of support people in
Germany France
Russia Tunisia the Netherlands and the
United States have demonstrated on his
behalf 130 European parliamentarians
have written to King Salman and aidan
Nobel laureates have shown their support
so to have many heads of state and
government including German Chancellor
Angela Merkel in the case of rapid
aerial support is particularly important
because in Saudi Arabia there are many
who believe he deserves his punishment
his own father for example and his
wife's family who filed court
proceedings for force divorce due to the
accusation of apostasy god is great the
spectators cried out as the lashes
rained down on his back and legs god is
great we currently find ourselves in
Ramadan which is also a month of mercy
King Salman the only one who can still
pardon right but now he must now display
his mercifulness I would like to close
with wife without his last blog entry
it's a quote from I welcome the only way
to deal with an unfree world is to
become so absolutely free that your very
existence is an act of rebellion ladies
and gentlemen this is the most important
price the box have ever awarded right
but are we it is a great honor for me to
present you with a freedom of speech
award I hope you will soon be able to
hold it in your own hands in freedom
thank you so much for what you said and
actually write but always knew about the
about the word and he's very happy to to
get it and it's a big support for him
and gives him a lot of hope that's what
itself told us but she also told us due
to personal reasons she cannot be with
us today but she's also very happy that
her husband got this award and she has a
message to tell us Messiah her look a
lil Hal during the hyatt a mechanic
greetings from Canada young boy today
it's a significant day for a whole who
are defending their right of freedom of
speech for dinner I know myself and I'm
a very well established institutions
like goodfellas granting my husband
right this award is that the just case
of wrath does not pertain to rifle own
but too many aggrieved whose rights have
been violated therefore I would like to
thank Dorcha villa and mr. peter
lindbergh the need for taking our price
case and he's continued commitment to
ralphs case right from the start I would
also like to call on the international
community of politicians and
humanitarian and civil organizations I
letter not to forget raw if his case and
the fate of his children is in your
hands it's love sincerely insaaf hater
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
director-general mr. Peter limburg
mr. Lombardo chabela as an international
broadcaster was one of the International
broadcast that covered the case of Rajiv
Badawi and now special thanks from
himself haider to you and what makes the
case of life better we so important that
Deutsche Welle is giving him this award
I think we are very happy to give this
award and I think the most important
thing we will do is that we continue to
report on the destiny and the fate of
rapid are we and I think it's he's an
example for being extremely courageous
and he and his family one has also to
say that his wife is great in fighting
for for his rights and so we will
continue covering this story and we as
Deutsche Welle we transport our values
of freedom of democracy of human rights
in every country of the world as we can
where we're not blocked or sends it in
any way and so I think we also have to
stand for these people who are really
fighting for these values and I'm very
happy that we had this I think quite
good idea to give this price out to
rapid are we it's actually a very good
idea because they were very happy and
self is happy and it's a hope and it's a
big support for them i can give you
their word but maybe for a picture
because they are not here would be so
fine but i hope that i will really can
give it to right but are we soon so
let's hope this together yeah sure
we all hope that right but now we can
get it soon and we came to the end now
that's why I would like to ask all the
winners and the jury member pleased to
join us for the final picture and ladies
and gentlemen I would like to ask you to
we want from here from the Deutsche
Welle from the global media forum from
the Bob's we would like to send a signal
to the whole word and to say we support
freedom of speech we support freedom of
expression that's why I would kindly ask
you to stand up and a big applause that
everywhere in the in the word can hear
your applause all over it's your time